alright Rebecca hello Rebecca great way
to drop remembers me you grew up with
both parents on that both parents until
about the third grade my divorce both
and then eventually just my dad
usually
mice my sister was also going through
the separation both back before thing
and she kind of chose to go with my mom
and I got
no I think it was more like our
personality sense at the time
what they had to do it have been working
at sister clothes okay
do you want to hear the full story the
whole story um I was dating this guy for
at this point about a year and I started
dating him when I was in high school and
when I got out I started waitressing at
this Mexican restaurant and my car got
totaled but my dad had bought the car
and me being young and naive I didn't
realize that because it was on my fault
my dad got the insurance money but he
didn't gave it to me to get into the car
and my boyfriend wanted me to move so I
needed to get another car quickly and so
I went on Craigslist and I saw an ad for
a bikini waitress at an LAX restaurant
and I was like hmm and stupidly didn't
look up the address or see what it was
and when I went it was an interview for
her to be a stripper I thought mystery
waitress and then he kept like pushing
the stripping envelope and I was like
huh
so I actually said no and I was trying
to find another job and then two weeks
later I still haven't found anything I
needed the money that was like okay I'll
just start what interesting and they
were like okay you can start waitressing
but not at the location that we
interviewed you out which is a really
nice location near LAX they moved me to
there one in the valley and it was like
for someone who had never even been in a
strip club to walk in there and then see
everything I was going on it was just
like a lot so I started waitressing
there and then I had a had a dancing
background previously for that and I'm
watching these girls and they were just
like not into it they're like I don't
know they weren't dancing really and so
I was talking to my manager about it he
was will stop talking [ __ ] and go up
there and do
and he gave me $100 which at the time
for me was a lot of money and I was like
okay and I made $1,000 and my first
stage set because there were people that
had seen me waitressing for a while and
they wanted me to do it
so I finally mimicked freaked out and I
was like oh my god why would I ever not
want to do this so I quit waitressing
that night and started dancing up sides
I think are very obvious funny uh
certain people do certain clubs don't
send forms they don't even document you
the downsides if you don't have
boundaries
people are gonna push them a lot and it
could put you in a very emotionally
uncomfortable position but I felt I
didn't have that issue really because it
I don't know let me try think about
other negatives
and your personality seems to be strong
so yeah yeah but it's like if you're
specially gonna know what's going on
there are some things that I thought
that I knew what was going on and then
people would throw something at you and
you're just like well I got anything you
know that was a thing like screwing you
over in a way that you could never even
imagine even the money that gets taken
from you and the people that you're
around it's a very different my soul and
then the stigma that comes with it I had
to hide it from my family for a long
time and obviously they that kind of
caught on after a while the way that
people treat you even go into the bank
and turning in your wine this is such a
big deal oh my goodness don't get me
started but I think it depends on the
person if you come into it with a bad
victim
LaRocco a better word mentality it's
gonna chew you up and spit you out but I
was able to kind of grab onto it and
make it into something great you see
very great grasp of what you're doing
could have
seem to be on drugs gonna be a drink or
use but I'm sure there's lots of app
you've seen right oh yeah oh yeah the
zoo girl when I first started ask me if
I had coke and I said the soda and this
person said wrong person to ask
I've seen people smoke meth next to me
in Vegas there's a lot going on yeah
yeah so for a while I had a trailer and
I drove from California all the way to
Florida all the way down went up to
Pennsylvania Indiana went across all the
way back over to California strip for
the strip club and sometimes not even
calling in advance just kind of like
showing up this one only one club in
Ohio made me be a feature because it was
a small town and they didn't want to
like it's a lot of competition you know
so they never like will call you a
feature because you're only gonna be
here for the weekend a future would be
someone that's paid to be there and
they're like almost like an act like
exactly but I just showed up and they
were like well we don't want to hire you
as a dancer because we're not
and traveling to do this rather than
saying it would agree I mean this
personal decision I it's like I like the
newness of it and like you learned so
much about the local culture
I loved Ohio I know I just spoke up like
the whole process of getting hired and
everybody was so nice and so
over-the-top a guy paid me man there
dancer to do an hour by ourselves he was
not in the room he paid a thousand
dollars for me and her to just be in a
room like what I was so kind Miami has
its own issues but it was a lot of fun
it's the one of the biggest strip clubs
and they have hours that start at $5,000
for an hour Vegas I worked at the
world's largest strip club there's so
many cool things in Tampa there was a
place where you had to pay your own
money to put your songs on the jukebox
to play for when you go on
and the place is like a shoebox there's
so many cool things that was in Miami at
11:00 it was a man who worked for
Kellogg we did one of those $5,000 hours
but the Cubs Club takes a huge cut of
that and then we did another hour before
that I was literally only there for me
five hours and I made 4,500 but that's
like just a thank you I am real
literally they brought masseuses up
we're watching porn we order we wondered
chocolate cake in French fries and I
showed him how to do handstands like I
literally didn't even dance for his
hangout I was wearing my clothes it was
awesome yeah especially in Vegas there
were like five or six different
instances where they literally would
just like want arm candy so we'd go to
like all these shows would go to dinner
but they wanted to be seen with you yeah
it's actually nice to hear yeah because
it's all about like
physical actors yeah these guys yep I
even went to Hawaii one time with a guy
we do had separate rooms sitting at home
this crazy
and so what is your family because they
I told them because there is a statement
well yeah but my dad shoots like boudoir
photography and I have done makeup for
him for a while yeah girl um so when I
told him I told them I don't want to
talk about this but this is what's
happening
they knew the club that I worked at
because I have a huge special that
everybody knows about in the area and I
was like please just don't go there
anymore I have a job we that was four
years ago we have not talked about it i
sounds lame but like my end goal end
goal is like I want to get a piece of
land somewhere and I want to be able to
like homestead like I really want to be
able to like grow my own food and do all
my own [ __ ] I like still my own clothes
or whatever but immediate more immediate
plans I'm planning on going into one
yes stripping is not I don't know if you
know that the girls pay to strip so
Vegas for example you pay to get your
sheriff's card like $75 pay to get your
alcohol and business license that could
be two to three hundred dollars then
then every single night when you walk in
the club you hand them $100 before you
even start your sheds I'm dead serious
so sometimes I leave having paid all
that money and I didn't make any money
so I owed money and that sucks when
you're on stage people are staring at
you you're not going to pay for
everything that you're doing you're
getting all bruised and everything it's
awful so not having that for sure money
sometimes really sucks yeah
and it affects your personal
relationships
I mean yes and no but I have the
wherewithal to know that those people
are not worth the time and I've kind of
found my friend group within it
I had the boyfriend at the time when I
started when he found out he broke up
with me
and at the time it was devastating but I
was like he's step away
but I've lost something like one
friendship over it but she was like
really super religious so I kind of
expected it yeah
but really honestly it hasn't really
changed much of my life
thank you thank you